[موسيقى]
يلا حيهم بث اليوم رئيس شركه مهاره
للموارد البشريه اللي اعتقد كثير منكم
يعرفونها من خدمه التاجير حقه الاعمال
المنزليه اللي اجرونهم بالساعه لكنها برضو
تخدم قطاع الاعمال باعمالهم مختلف
التخصصات كيف الطباخ طبيعي ممرض عامل اللي
تبيه خبره الشركه في السوق حدود العشر
سنوات ومدرجه في السوق الرئيسي وايراداتها
السنويه تعدت المليار ريال من بعد ثالث
سنه تاسيس لهم في السوق بنغطي مع ضيفنا
اليوم اشياء كثير تخص شركات الموارد
البشريه وعملها مثلا نموذج عملهم كيف
تقدرون الاعمال اللي يستخدمونهم بالالاف
مدربين وجاهزين للعمل بندخل في تفاصيل
اكثر حتى عن احصائيات العماله وتحديات
الاستقدام والمشاكل اللي يواجهونها عاده
سواء في البيوت او في الشركات وش وجهه نظر
الضيف في الناس اللي تقاطعون معهم في
السوق سواء كانت مثلا مكاتب استقدام ولا
تطبيقات توظيف وحتى الشركات الحكوميه اللي
توظف للجهات الحكوميه تفاصيل كثير وارقام
كثيره غطيناها في حلقه اليوم حلقه ثريه
جدا وجسمه اتمنى تعجبكم
يعني
بس في الرياض تغيرت الكوره تماما يقولون
برضو رجعتي اصابات
[ضحك]
لعبتي المفضله صراحه تقرون بطل فيها الا
والله حققت بطوله فيها في جده في بطولات
والمدارس يعني المستوى المدارس في جده
في المتوسطه تقريبا
وكنت من افضل اللاعبين فيها
يعني بطول المدارس كانوا يسوونها يعني في
مواسم والصيف كانسون مدارس بطولات
الداخليه في قوانين غير المعرفه كانت يعني
ما هي رسميه مره يعني يسمحون بالفرق فيها
ولا يعني
احيانا الفتره ذيك
ما اذكرها
حق اللعبه من الفرفر
في قطاع الموارد البشريه
في ناس يسمونه
[ضحك]
بس يجيكم تعليقات
وتجاره بشر وهذولي هل هم مستعبدين
المفهوم غريب شويه عندهم يعني هذول موظفين
يعني عماله وقوه عامله تبغى تشتغل يعني
فهم يجون الدول ويعملون في شركات لكن على
اساس احنا هذا اللي ننظمهم ونرتبهم فيعني
غريب يعني غريب انهم يعني يعني يفسرونها
كانت جار البشر ما لها دخل بالجار البشر
مفهوم اخر تماما هو انك تشغل الاطفال اقل
من العمر 15 سنه هذه متاجره للبشر
بكلامة يعني
احنا بالعكس الدول الدول كلها شرق اسيا
والهند وغيرها هي تورد القوى العامله
للبلدان الاستوديو هو رسميا بعقود رسميا
يرسلونهم لنا للخليج عشان يعملون واحنا
بالعكس اليوم ننظمهم وشرعهم وياخذون
حقوقهم بشكل اوسع كل واحد بعقد رسمي كل
واحد يعني وصلنا لدرجه انه كل عامل يقدر
يشوف حقوقه كامله من ابلكيشن من امور يعني
سياسيه اكثر منها يعني بعض الدول يعني
اللي تبغى تطلع شيء على دوله يقول لك انه
حقوق الانسان وحقوق انسان وغيرها لكن
طالما انه يعمل وظيفه رسميه طالما انا
ياخذ مستحقاته البول طالما ياخذ ساعات عمل
وساعات راحته اول باول طالما منافع وكل
اخذها طالما ياخذ اجازه ياخذها ويسافر
بلده ويرجع عشان كذا تغير نظام وزاره
الموارد البشريه غيرت نظام من من نظام
كفاءه كان يقال عليه سابقا عقود انت جايب
عقد تقعد سنه بتقعد سنتين تقدر تغير
باريحيه من شركه لشركه
نظمت حوكمه القطاع الابعد درجه صرنا حنا
في الحوكمه في السعوديه يمكن من افضل
الدول بلا مبالغه على مستوى يعني اقليمي
على مستوى العالم في حوكمه حقوق العماله
بشكل عام هو سبب تاسيس شركه قبل يعني قبل
قبل
ممتاز
الشركات المواد البشريه موجوده في العالم
من زمان من الثمانيه وتسعينات في شركات
ممبا والجروب احد اكبر شركات العالم
والشركات الكبرى لكن دخل
هي موجوده لكن دخلت تحولت الى الصناعه
يعني من يوم دخلنا حنا كالفكره السعوديه
ولا هي الفكره موجوده في اوروبا في امريكا
اتكلم الفكره بشكل عام موجوده وحتى يقول
لك تجاره بشر ما في تجار بشر طب موجوده في
الغرب
فبدينا حنا يمكن في 2012 طلعت اللائحه
طبعا الفكر قديمه من الداخليه
لائحه تنظيم
قطاع الاستخدام والمواد البشريه في
المملكه حلو طلعت لائحه من برج السويد من
وزاره المواد البشريه وبدات تنظم وترخص
الشركات وفي رسمات ويودع وفي ضمان بنكي
وضع يودع في وزاره المواد البشريه لاجل
تنظيم السوق بدينا يمكن تنظيم بدا 2012
2013 بدات الشركات تاخذ تراخيصها وحنا
اخذنا الترخيص من البدايات ليش بدينا
الموضوع طبعا مهاره يمكن عرابها الدكتور
عبد الله عمرو
ومؤسسها احد مؤسسها وهو طبيب باور كويس
ومتخصص في الاورام وهو السمك طبيه وقبلها
مستشفى التخصصي
كويس غيرناها الى موارد بشريه ليش ممتاز
احنا
مفهوم تغير كويس احنا ما نجيب عامله
منزليه زي السابق كانت مكاتب استخدام
موجوده احنا قلنا لازم نطلع بشيء جديد
لازم القطاع يتغير جبنا التجارب العالميه
شفناها
وشفنا شركات الكبرى في العالم كيف ماشيه
في قطاع الموارد البشريه اشي مفهوم عندهم
جبنا شركه استشاريه حنا
استراتيجيه كامله للشركه
استراتيجيه وشفناها ما عاد في ما هو شيء
عماله منزليه وبس المفهوم اللي موجود
اليوم
كويس لكن هي عمات قطاع اعمال للبزنس نفس
بشكل عام قطاع الاعمال قطاع خاص نخدمهم
بمهن عماله او قوه عامله ماهره وغير ماهره
كنا مركزين على قطاع الاعمال كويس وبدانا
وش نوع العماله اللي كنتوا قوه عامله
ماهره وغير ماهره يعني جبنا قوتنا يمكن
انا جاي من قطاع القطاع الطبي الصحي الطبي
فركزنا على قطاعات قطاعات طبي قطاع
الضيافه قطاع المقاولات
كبيره زي عمات النظافه
اعمالها عماله مساعده للمقاولات
تحميل وتنزيل هذه يسمون عماله غير ماهره
الاعمال الماهره المهنيه اللي فنيه يعني
ومهندسين واطباء وتمريض وترى يعني مصطلح
العامل يطلق على السعودي وغير السعودي
يعني وهذا موجود عندها اليوم
فبدانا بدانا 2013 يمكن تجربه مهاره
بدانا بثلاث الاف عامل يعني في 6 شهور سبع
شهور وبدايتنا شفنا عدد كبير مو بسيط 3000
عاما وحنا لسه في ما اسسنا البنيه التحتيه
حقنا فكانت مرحله يعني تجريبيه لنا انا
انا ما كنت ما كنت عارف مفهوم الاستقدام
بشكل كبير يعني ما تعلمت ولا فلسه الاولى
هذيك
اللي تسويه عشان تستخدمها العدد الكبير
في قطاع الاعمال يتعاقد مع شركات في مختلف
القطاعات اللي يطلب لك ميه اللي يطلب لك
500 يطلب لك الف بمهن مختلفه يعني تروح
قطاع التجزئه يقول لك انا ابغى لي والله
مناديل مبيعات من مصر من السودان من عده
جنسيات وتروح عند الشركه متخصصه في موضوع
التوصيل هنديه تروح عند مثلا شركات مصانع
يقول ابو عماله
يعني حاجه تحميه وتنزيل او تغليف او شيء
لوحات فاحنا نتعاقد معهم ونجيب لهم
الاعمال القوه العامله بحسب طلبهم حتى
المقابلاتهم يسوونها بس هذا العملاء انت
نقصت الحين جاك عميل طلب اتفهم مثلا
استخدام عامل عاملين
احنا الوزاره تعطينا كوتها في عدد تاثيرات
متاحه لنا عدد معين عدد معين العميل
المستهدف لازم يكون عنده
متوافق معه في موضوع انه عنده عدد سعوديين
كافي ويستوعب العدد اللي بيجيك يعني اليوم
لو نطاقات ونازله او عدد ما هو يعني
يستوعب 100 ما اقدر اجيب له 500
يعني التاشيرات المتاحه لوميه لكن عندك حد
معين تشتغل فيه بغض النظر عن عدد عملائك
وعن طبيعه مفتوح الى عشره الاف وكل ما جبت
كل ما افتتاح لي عشره الاف تاشيره ثانيه
كل ما جبت قوه عامله دخلوا السعوديه على
طول يتحلي الفرق يعني اليوم عندي متاح
عشره الاف تاشيره موجوده عندي
الشركه تكون مثلا عندها سعوده ولا لان
المستفيد هو لازم لازم اربطهم نعم لازم
اربطهم على جير عشان اسوي لكم متواكب
متوافق مع نطاقات ولا لو اقدر اجيب له
لحاله وهذا كان عدد صار عدد القوى عامله
كثير صارت بالمئات الالاف عندنا لكن
الاجانب وحنا متواجدين لازم نوظف
السعوديين ويطلع له عدد معين من اتاحه
التاشيرات وان ياخذ التاشيرات من عندي
مباشره
تجيب له القوى العامله اللي يبيها وهذه
التاشيرات انت ملزمه انك تكون يعني
الاعمال في شركات ثانيه تشتغلون عندك لا
اصلا في الشركات مش عندي انا
حتى لو العميل ما عجبه عامل عمليه ثلاثه
عشره يرجعون عندي وانا ادورهم على الشركات
على السوق فيكون عندي انا مسؤول
هذول عندي هدول عندنا اسكانات خاصه فينا
يكونوا عندنا يروحون بالساعه ويرجعون عنده
بالسكن فهذا لو بيرفعون لكم بالعيد
بس هي كويته مؤكده مثلا اعطاك عشره الاف
الوزاره جبت الفين اليوم بصير يتاح لك
ثمانيه الاف كل ما جبتي يرجع لك يعني حلو
فانتم بديتوا في تاجير او توفير العماله
الماهره نعم
يمكن الخط الزمني حقنا يمكن في تغيرنا شوي
مع التغيرات التشريعات
تغيرت وقتها في 2015 يعني الوزاره عزمتنا
نجيب عشرين بالمئه من مجموعه عدد العماله
القوى العامله المستحقها انا اللي عندي
لازم يكون العماله المنزليه
عشرين بالمئه قالوا عندي عشره عامل اليوم
لازم يكون عم
نغذي السوق يعني السوق يكون فيه يعني نخدم
قطاع الافراد ما هو بس فقط
هو الاساس انه نقدم احنا خدمتين في
بداياتنا اللي هو القطاع الاعمال وقطاع
الافراد حلو كويس وليش قطاع الاماكن
والسوق ما هو منظم سابقا تعرف ياخذ واحد
تاشيرات ويجيب عماله ويت
ينظمون سوق العمل شافوا السوق الاول يعني
عمالها سائبه واللي يجيك يقول لك فيزا حره
ونشتغل بكيفي في الشارع لكن عن طريق شركات
مواد بشريه الكلام هذا مو فيه لان انا
محوكب محوكب من الوزاره يشوفون العامل
اللي عندي وين يشتغل عند اي عميل بالضبط
فحوكمه عندنا كبيره جدا الوزاره اشتريت
على نظام حوكمه والتزام قوي قوي جدا لا
بعد درجه
فاعرف انا عامل في اي مدينه في اي مكان
بالضبط في اي شركه وين بالضبط تشتغل هذه
كلها موجوده عنا مرصوده حلو هذا في
الشركات السوق ما تلقاها كثير يعني اللي
عندهم تاشيرات ومباشره لكن عندنا محوكمين
وهذا احد التنظيمات اللي طلعت انه طلعوا
شركات مواد بشريه تنظم السوق وتحكمه فاحنا
على اساس كذا ولد لقطاع حقنا بستخدم
يختلف عن الاستقدام ما يختلف هي نموذج عمل
واحد اليوم تجي تقول ابغى الف عامل وعندك
استيعاب الف من التاشيرات هل تتكلم شركه
بره تقول جيبولي
الفلبين ابغى من الهند ابغى باكستان ابغى
من امريكا ابغى من كندا اي دول كويس نروح
نطلع التاشيرات نتواصل معاه مكاتب التوظيف
الخارجيه اللي هناك كويس انه نبغى هذه
المهن بالاعداد هذه ونرسل ونروح السفارات
في نماذج نعبيها عندهم ونطلب الطلبات هذي
وبعدها ترسل المكاتب التوظيف الخارجيه
مكانه التوظيف الخارجيه تسوي اعلانات
عندهم ويجمعون اكبر عدد ممكن يطلعون
الشركه زياره يسوون مقابلات واللي
يختارونهم نكمل اجراءاتهم ويجيبهم
السعوديه مقابلات الالف واحد ممكن
يعني ما هي بسيطه
مثلا سباكين كهرباء شركه مقاولات حريصه
يكون عندها حداد نجار سباك كهربائي لا
نسوي اختبارات هناك
المحاكاه كامله تشوفون مكان كانه عماره
ويجون نجوم نختبرهم في تركيب
ادوات الكهرباء
نجربهم نختبرهم فعلا اختبار اسمه
الشركات اللي بره حنا نسويها مع المكاتب
بس يختارون نفس العميل يجي معنا يقول ابغى
هذا وهذا يتجاوز الاختبار يقول ابغاها حلو
نجهز كل الامور السيت اب كامل حنا نجهز
بتجهيز كامل
العميل يجي معنا يقول خلاص تبغى هذا الفئه
في بعضهم يقول لك لا احنا عندنا خبره
كبيره في عده تخصصات كويس هنقول احنا
بنجيب لك اياهم على مسؤوليتنا اذا ما
ناسبك عادي حنا يعني نحل الموضوع
واستخدامهم من السعوديه يتم دفعات يجون
كيف قاعد يدخلون
حسب الطيارات يعني مقاعد وكم ياخذ وقت
ثلاثه شهور عشان يجيك من شهرين الى ثلاثه
شهور عشان تبدا تجيك العماله الهند شهر
شهر ونصف
وبعدين طلع اكثر من فريق يعني مو انا اروح
بنفس الشركه هذي بس استنى اخلص عشان اجيب
العميل
يجون عندنا ما يقعدون فتره طويله يقعدون
اسبوع كويس ناخذ منهم نسوي عقودهم ان
الصور منهم نحطهم في السيستم بياناتهم زحص
الطبي
نعطيهم برنامج تعريفي عن السعوديه وتقاليد
السعوديه والامور هذه تتجاوزوها يعني في
في محاذير معينه يعطيها وعامل نعلمهم على
بطاقه الصراف يعني فيها شيء ما يعرفونها
في بلدانهم فبدا نعطيهم نموذج تعريفي كامل
وانت بتحاول تحركه للعملاء على طول مباشره
على طول كان بسرعه وناخذ فحص طبي طلع
الفحص الطبي سليم نطلع الاقامه حقه يطلع
التامين الطبي حقه ما يطلع من عندنا الا
هو كامل يعني طالع من عند العائله العميل
بشكل يعني انه كل شيء معه وكم نسبه يعني
انت ما شاء الله وصلتوا
ما شاء الله عشر سنوات جبنا 130 الف عمل
ما شاء الله تبارك الله بس اليوم العمال
اللي موجودين اليوم على كفالتكم عندي
عندنا اليوم ولا جالس معك الحين
37,500 ما شاء الله اجمالا على مر السنين
كم النسبه اللي كم نسبه منهم بشكل
نسبه منهم يكونون عندكم لانكم شغل
والبقيهم يشتغلون بالنسبه اللي عندكم هذي
كم تحرصون انها ما تتجاوز شوف اليوم قطاع
الاعمال الى
2020 بدايه 2020 كنا ولله الحمد 99%
موجودين عند العملاء
[موسيقى]
يدخل يشوف كل حقوقه فيه ينزل الخصومات
الاوفر تايم امتيازات كل شيء بقي لك كذا
بالنسبه للعميل عنده برضو الضمان المنزليه
مثلا
عقود واضحه تماما ومسهله ميسره ترى العميل
يعني في عمل استراتيجيه معي من 2013 الى
اليوم معنا كويس
مرتاحين بشكل عام ليش لانه تلقى انا موفر
عليه كاش كويس هو لو جاب عامل عليهم
مباشره
كويس لكن عن طريق انا يقسط على 24 شهر
فيقول لك العميل يا اخي خلني انا ابغى
الكاش هذا يستفيد منه في توسع خلني اجيب
القوه العامله خلي الشركات تزيد 300 ريال
400 ريال في الشهر من كل عامل لكن في
الاخير انا مستفيد بس العامل هل برضو يحق
له يقول بروح لشركه ثانيه تصير وانا ما
اضغط على العامل ابد اذا ما توافقوا مع
بعض اجيبه ونسوي له يعني عندنا شيء اسمه
استرشاد
فريق خاص مشرفين يرشدون العامل يقولوا
يعني يحاولون انه يخلونا يرجع ما يرجع ما
قبل ما اقدر اضغط عليه فشوف العميل اخر
في عصر رقم متغير باستمرار المواكبه هي
اساس النجاح ولاننا رواد المستقبل الرقمي
نوظف خبراتنا وقدراتنا لنمكن نبتكر نبدع
في تبني احدث التقنيات وتوفير الحلول
بكفاءه وذكاء
وكيف نموذج العمل عندكم بشكل عام سواء
وشركات
بشكل عام
هل انكم تحملون العمل كامل التكلفه حق
استخدام العامل ورواتبه زاد هامش الرب
حقكم
[موسيقى]
كامل التكلفه
يعني انا عندي مؤسسه شخصيه حاليا فامي
اريح لي لان ابغى الكاش ريحي ناخذ من شركه
مواد البشريه فعلا انا ماخذ منه شكل عندي
تحت التاشيرات لكن اقدر اصدر التاشيرات من
وسطكم واخذها لكن الشركات تريحني
في حاله استخدمت له اذا كان العامل
المتواجد هنا ممكن ياخذوا فقط برات حتى
حتى للمتواجد هنا اقدر انقل خدمات وعلى
الشركه وهم يسوون والشركات الموارد
البشريه
والله والله
يعني اليوم
الوزاره يعني دخلنا مع الوزاره في موضوع
انه نخفض اسعار العماله المنزليه كويس
وطلعت باقات مؤخرا يمكن الاسبوع هذا طلعت
باقات جديده مرنه ومحدده
بسعر منافس جدا احنا ما نكتب كثير
مره
سبعه
ثمانيه بالمئه في السوق حقي انقطع في
شركات اللي نضجت كثير وبدات توفر مصاريفها
وبدات تسوي يمكن توصل عشره 11% بس حلو
تدفع قيمه الاستقدام في حال اضطريت انك
تستخدم العامل بس اذا كان موجود اتصور
الدفع الرواتب دفع الرواتب حقك رسوم
الحكوميه زائد رسومي التكاليف بشكل
عندك راتبه وعندك الرسوم الاداريه حق
الشركه هي ثلاث عناصر رئيسيه هذي حلو كان
في تكلفه بتحويل العامل من شركه لشركه
طبعا تدفع رسوم رسوم النقل الخدمات
يسمونها من شركه لشركه هذه كم تقريبا
السنه الثانيه تصير اربعه الاف سنه 6000
اذا نقل مره ثانيه اذا نقل مره ثالثه تزيد
صورت عندكم استثناء او شيء لا هذا المشكلة
ما حد يعرف الناس يحسبونا نكسب كثير
ترتفع بشكل تراكمي تلقى العميل يقول ابغاه
لانه فاهم البزنس حقي وانا مرتاح العميل
مختلف الاحجام الشركات من عندنا مشاهد
صغيره متناهيه
عندنا متوسطه وعندنا كبير وعندنا عملاق
كبيره العملاقه اللي عندهم 1500 الف اللي
عندهم 3000 عامل مطاعم مقاهي واجد يقول لك
وفي مطاعم كثير جدا عملائنا مستمرين
معناتهم يقول انا مرتاح لاني اقدر اغير
بسهوله ما عجبني هذا اقول له لاني انا
اقدر اوديه العميل اخر اوصل العميل اخر هو
ما يقدر انه في شركات زيكم
[موسيقى]
ما يقعدون لان الوصول جديد خلال اسبوعين
تلقاهم بس تحافظون عليها ولا او مستمر أنا
وصلنا احنا مرحله يعني عشر سنوات انا اعرف
ايش المهني اللي اجيبها وفي اي موسم
بالضبط ومتى راح تطلع
كويس
فاحنا عندنا مواسم في السنه موسم رمضان
موسم الحج موسم الصيف من بياخذ اعماله
اكثر يشوفو قطاع التجزئه مستواك والمحلات
يطلبون عدد عماله كبير فاحنا بنجهز امورنا
هنا في الوقت هذا تروح مكاتب الاستخدام
للعملة تجربتي
شهرين ثلاثه يقول لك ما عندنا توكل على
الله حنا الان انا اجيب في الشهر الان
اجيب 1500 الفين امام منزليه لنعرفهم
بيروحون
والاسطر تحتاجهم قبل رمضان فنجيب اكبر عدد
ممكن عشان والله نلبيات الاسر رغم ان ترى
ربحيتنا في العماله المنزليه يعني
انا اعرف صراحه شركه مهاره من العمل
المنزليه ومن خدمه العملاء المنزليه
الساعه كم تشكل ايرادات الخدمه هذه
وقلت لك انه وصلنا قطاع الاعمال شكل 75%
من الايرادات
منزليه برضو الوزاره المواد البشريه عليها
عبء كبير وعليها ضغوطات كبيره انها توفر
عدد كبير منزليه عشان تلبي احتياجات الوسط
وصرنا حنا نسعى بشكل كبير ونجيب اكبر عدد
ممكن منزليه ما قصرت صراحه يعني السعوديه
اليوم بلا مجامله وزاره مواد البشريه
عندنا
وقعت يمكن من الدول المحوكمه على مستوى
الشرق
الاوسطين عقود اتفاقيات مع دول كثير مع
الفلبين مع اندونيسيا مع سيراليون مع
بروناي مع اثيوبيا بروندي سوري مع
اوغندا مع كينيا مع الدول على اساس موضوع
كويس وهذا بالعكس ينظم العمل كثير
ويساعدنا في انه يعني نكون دوله محوكمه
فعلا وهذا اللي صاير اليوم اتفاقيات كثير
مهن جنسيات متاحه مش ما تبي يجي منها حتى
نيجيري عند الدول بشكل ما تتصور حتى تمريض
المنزلي ما شاء الله عندنا عقود كثيره مع
الفلبين الهند تونس ضد الدول
الخدمه العمل المنزليه وجع راس اكثر من
يعني معليش تقول عباره منتجه ما هو
تتعامل مع بشر كويس ما هو مع علبه مويه
ولا كرتونه تحطها في مكان وتسوي البشر هذا
لوحه يعني له احتياجات معينه وله امور
كثيره
يعني ما هو زي منتج معين تحطه في مستودع
وبس عشان كذا متعب بالعمل فيه
شكلهم اكثر من عادي علامات نعم لانك انت
اتخيل عندك مثلا اليوم انا عندي
14 الف عامل منزلي وعامله فنتعامل مع 14
الف عميل
بينما عندي
24 الف قطاع اعمال اليوم واتعامل يمكن معه
600 شركه تخيل 14 الف عميل في الافراد
و600 عميل في قطاع الاعمال
العالي الهادف في العوامل المنزليه لانه
ما انت يمكن 600 عميل تقدر تحكمه وتقدر
انك ترفع نسبه الرضا بشكل كويس واحترافيه
معينه وخلاص عميل واحد يكون راضي عنك
فتخيل العميل هذا عنده 3000 فانت نسبه
ثلاث عامل مع نسبه رضا واحد على عميل واحد
لكن عندك 14 الف عامله كويس و14 الف عميل
14 عميل يعني يمكن ما في رضا
كويس هذا ما راح يقبل مع هذا وكم متوسط
الوقت اللي عاده تنقذون العملات المنزليه
في الخدمه
الساعه في احنا خدمه الساعه احنا شويه
مهاره عندنا اربع ساعات ست ساعات ثمان
ساعات عشر ساعات و12 ساعه لكن اكثرها اربع
ساعات فهي زيارتين في اليوم اللي ياخذ
ثمان ساعات زياره واحده يعني
هذا الخدمه الساعه لكن خدمه المقيمه هذه
تقعد بشهر شهرين
يختلف كل كل مدينه لها سوقها يعني يعني
الرياض كبيره يعني احنا خمسين بالمئه من
60 من 45% من القوى العامله يعني المنزليه
في الرياض
توسعها كبير يعني والنظره لها المستقبليه
واعده وراح يتدبل عدد السكان فيعني عدد
كبير جدا فيها وش ابرز الشكاوي
المنزليه مقارنه بالقطاع الاعمال
شوف احنا
تجربتنا من العملاء ممتاز
تجربه كبيره جدا اللي هي اكثر شكاوي
موجوده
كويس
وهذا ساعدنا يعني كل احنا كل شهر
ناخذ تقييم اداء العملاء او تقييم العملاء
كويس وهذي نروح نبني عليها ونعالجها يعني
نشوف ايش المساء ونسويها حنا اساسنا
اكاديميه يمكن اول اكاديميه في المملكه
واكبر اكاديميه في مملكه
اكاديميه تخص العماله المنزليه تدريبها
تدريب في مكان تلقى بيت محاكاه رسميه
محاكاه الكوي للغسيل للطبخ وكل شيء وفيها
12 برنامج تقريبا برنامج التدبير المنزلي
برنامج الطبخ برنامج الناني اللي هي حق
الاطفال برنامج رعايه كبار السن وببرنامج
مرافقه المريض وكل برنامج تحته كذا
البرنامج الصغير يعني زي الناري في اللي
يتعامل مع ابو شهر في اللي يتعامل مع برج
الطفل ابو شهرين وسته شهور سنه كل واحد
وببرنامج ومن يتعاقدهم مع الاطفال
جايبين والله ترتيب حتى السي بي ار يعني
حقين عاش القلب والرئوي نسوي لهم
يعني بلع له شيء او شيء صرنا نجرب
الخادمات انه كيف تتعامل مع الطفل كويس
اللي هم العاملات لكن يقول لك الاكاديميه
هذه ما تخدم مهاره بس احنا سويناها يعني
استثمار
وصلنا كل العاملات حقنا نجربهم عندهم
مع شركات منافسه لنا يوقعون ويقدروا
يدربون
ابرز الشكاوي الهجوم العمج وما اقصد يعني
ممكن تاخذها بشكل عام مع الشركات
الناس اللي مهتمين في القطاع هذا
العامله تقول لك ابغى تتشرط ابغى الواي
فاي عندي في البيت ابغى الواي فاي عشان
اشتغل ابغى استخدم الجوال يعني هذه ابرز
الاشياء بس احنا نعالجها والقطاع الاعمال
قطاع الاعمال يعني يقول لك
العامل مسوي مشاكل ما يبغى يشتغل مضرب زي
كذا هذول نعالجهم في الوقت لكن مشاكلهم
اقل من العماله المنزليه كثير خلال عشر
سنين شفت فيه اتمنى ان تجاوبة بس شفت فيه
تطور في تعامل الناس مع
العماله سواء اقطع الاعمال
يعني بتقيسه بنسبه
يعني صار يعني من العماله القوى العامله
صارت اهتمام عليها بشكل كبير يعني العميل
يحرس انه يبغى راته وينزل بدري عشان ما
يصير مشاكل ولا
يعني يتقاعد في العمل شوي صار حريص عامله
زمان غير كويس نشوف اول يختلف كويس
الدول تتغير يعني ودول تنضج كويس
والاشتراطات اكثر تغير العالم كله بشكل
عام صار العالم حريص على على على يعني
المواطنين حقه على مجتمعه فحديث زي
الفلبين فلبين قويه جدا في تشريعاتها قويه
جدا في المحافظه على عمالتها لو صار اي
عامل شيء تصير الدوله كلها تسوي مشاكل او
تسوي يعني كل شويه تراسلك وشويه تبغى تحل
مشكله احنا حريصين جدا نتواكب باشتراطات
حق وزاره المواد البشير وزاره التشريعات
قويه في التعامل مع العمل حتى حمايه
الاجور يوم عشره من الشهر لازم تنزل كل
راتب العماله خمسه ما نزلت يوقف سيستم
عليك فمحوكم القطاع بشكل كبير يعني ما في
احد ما زرات ما في احد يعني تلقاها يعني
يتقدم من الشركه وما ياخذ العلاج الطبي
حقه او او او كل هذه محوكمه ومشرعه وعلي
كشركات تقطاع مواد البشريه محوكمه اكثر
حوككم اكثر لانه حنا مرخصين والرقابه
علينا عاليه جدا حلو ذكرتي بشغله
التسجيل كلي من ثالث سنه ومن بعد ثالث سنه
مهاره
تتجاوز مليار هذا كان شيء خاص في مهاره
ولا الشركات في مستفيده من
العدد اللي جبناه عدد كبير يعني اول سنه
2013 عامل ثاني سنه جبنا 14 الف عامل كويس
حنا
[موسيقى]
لا عدد كبير فانت لما جبنا اطباء
الرواتبهم على 4050000 اه اوكي في اعمال
راتبه فانت تحسبها وتحسب الرسوم الاداريه
فهذول ما هي كلها ما هي ارباح ايرادات
كويس لكن كم نسبه الاعمال الماهره من غير
ماهره الماهره
[موسيقى]
الغير ماهر لو كان غير لو كانت الماهره
ستين بالمئه كان مليارين
عندك عدد كبير صرنا وصلنا في
2015 وصلنا تقريبا
كل ما ارتفعنا ما نزلنا عن العشرين الف
والتاني بيكون ايراداتك فوق المليار حلو
فاتصور اغلبها من الاعمال المعرفه ولا غير
ظاهره تكون منخفضه مخدرات وتكاليفهم
في مبيعات واجد ما شاء الله
يعني احتاج استوفيها عشان الشركه في
القطاع واضح انها صعبه اي احد يقدر والله
القطاع محوكه مره مره
عجبني الكلام هذا الحين
عشان كذا
[ضحك]
قطاع موارد بشريه مئه مليون ريال لحد
الادنى اوكي
[ضحك]
تقدر تجيب عدد اعمال كثيره عندك
37 الف
أصله الاربعين الف ونص كان عندك 45 الف
نطاق اصغر اصغر فينا فيها انشطه اقل اللي
هو العماله المنزليه وفي اللي اكبر شوي
اللي هي عماله منزليه زائده زائد خدمه
الساعه
العماله المنزليه مقيمه بس خمسه مليار
ريال
العماله بتضيف خدمه الساعه 20 مليار
وفيه اللي هنا نشاط موارد بشريه اللي فيها
اسناد سعوديين بعد هذه 100 مليار ريال
ابو خمسه وعشره ليش في فرق بين 25 قدم في
عشرين خمسه مليون في عشرين مليون ليش في
فرق بين
الساعه لانها تكاليفها عاليه لازم يكون
عندك باصات يكون عندك اسكانات لانه حجم
التكاليف مصاريفه اعلى
بسكون عندك في السكن سكناتك لازم توفر عدد
توزع في الاحياء في المدينه يعني ما هو
بسيط على السكن
قويه جدا فبالتالي يعني تكون مصاريف عاليه
جدا يعني الايجارات الاسكانات ما هي سهله
ما هي رخيصه اليوم قبل 2019 كانت رخيصه
كويس يعني ممكن تستاجر عماره 300 عامل
فيها كويس 350 400 الف ريال ايجارها
وتجهزها يمكن سبع مئه الف كويس اليوم نفس
العماره 300 عامل تدفع ايجار فيها 850 الف
دبل ايجارات ارتفعت
شو اسمه التجهيز يزيد معك مليون مليون
ونصف الرسوم ارتفعت بس اجمالا تصور انك
تسكنهم باماكن مثلا في جنوب الرياض في
خدمه الساعه يجب تكون قريب من المنطقه
اللي بتخدمها عشان عندك وقت هذا اللي
بيشتغل بالسياره لازم
يعني ربه الاسره تنتظر العمل تجي الساعه
سبعه ثمانيه الصباح
فانت لو انك بعيد ممكن توصل البيت الساعه
تسعه عشره الرياض مثلا فلازم تكون في
الرياض لازم تكون في قريب من الاحياء
بتخدم شمال الرياض يبغى لك ثلاثه سكنات
لحاله سكنين عشان توصل لكل في وقت زمني
معين
نعم هذه تكاليف عاليه تكون عشان كذا
ارتفعت التكاليفنا حنا والناس يقولون يمكن
عندهم نظره ان اسعارنا غاليه هو ارتفاع هو
لسبب
اليوم ارتفاع صار هذا سبب ارتفاع سعر
العقار والايجارات والامور هذه كلها تاثر
حتى على سعر الخدمه والرسوم والاشياء كلها
ارتفعت وبالتالي تؤثر عليك
فهذه هي
والموديل زي ما قلت لك عشان تقول خدمه
الساعه لازم تكون قريب من الاحياء اللي
بتخدمها على اساس مده الوصول وقت اذا فيه
ابدا شركه رسم الخمسه مليون عشرين مليون
يعني على الاقل فيه عدد اكبر مناسك القطاع
هذا يشتغلون فيه والان في شركه مثلا في
[موسيقى]
بحكم اني انا نائب رئيس اللجنه الوطنيه
وعضو مجلس تنسيقي فعارف الشركات اللي
بتنزل قريب في السوق وبالعكس ندعمهم صدقا
يعني احنا انا حريص جدا ما بقول
لا انا حريص جدا اكبر عدد ممكن من الشركات
تنزل في سوق الاسهم بس وش المشكله
التحديات اللي يمكن تغيب عن
بالجديد النوع والمعرفه
المعرفه في واحد تلقى عنده فلوس عنده
مبالغ وعنده
لكن ما عنده معرفه حلو اللي يسمع انه
اتصور يقول وش المعرفه اللي بيلان
اسكنهم
[موسيقى]
انا ابغى اعرف الجانب اللي ما يبين لهم من
هاللقاط تتعامل معه دول تتعامل مع مكاتب
توظيف خارجيه تتعامل مع
هيومن مع بشر هم يوصلون نموذج عملهم
الداخلي كيف يصير كيف ترعاهم كيف يقدم
الخدمه لهم كيف العميل عندك اكثر من محور
تشتغل عليه العميل رحله العميل لحالها هذه
اجراءات ما هي بسيطه رحله العامل اجراءات
ايضا ما هي بسيطه فالرحله من قبل ما يوصل
السعوديه هذه تبدا من هناك
الشيء اللي تفاجات بصعوبته
اختلاف في الدول الاجراءات الدول هذا كان
من اكبر عوائق اللي عندنا اختلاف يعني
[موسيقى]
كفاءات عندها معرفه وقدره انها تجيب
البزنس وفي ناس لازم يكون عندهم فكر فكر
كيف اطور قطاعي وكيف اطور الشركه وكيف
اخلي شركتي واعده وتكون منافسه في السوق
في نشاطات كبيره في شركات كثيره بدات من
الصفر وما شاء الله عليها صارت تضاهي الان
انه من ضمن الشركات اللي تدعمها او الدوله
راح تدعمها في مجالات كثيره في الخارج
والداخل
[موسيقى]
وعلى مدى العشر سنين الماضيه كيف تشوف
التشريعات خاصه وزاره الموارد البشريه
يمكن التشريعات او قيدت يعني هو يشوف
الوزاره عليها حمل كبير جدا وعليها ضغوطات
كبيره جدا
وعلينا ملفات كبيره جدا كويس وضمه لها
وزارات كويس صارت وزاره واحده
اولوياتها كثير في الموضوع البطاله في
موضوع
الخدمه الاجتماعيه في موضوع الامانه في
موضوع التاشيرات في موضوع التستر الموجود
في السوق في موضوع العماله المتكدسه في
ملفات كثيره مالها موضوع تغيب العماله
الغروبها والشغل السوق السوداء اللي موجود
ترى ملفات لها حمل كبير كويس تشريعات كل
ما تزيد عندنا والتغيراتها كثيره
كل يوم يطلع التنظيم جديد قارات جديده
مثلا
برنامج تحسين علاقه التعاقديه للنزل مؤخرا
هذا تنظيم
الى التعاقد هذا ما هو بسيط فانت تغير
منظومه كامله وهذا تغيير يصير اثره على
مدى طويل يعني ما هم ما هو سهل
متعاقد معامل سنتين جايبهم برا النظام
يقدر ينقل اي شركه اخرى
افعل شعرت بها الاثر ولا بدينا نتاثر شوي
بعدين بعدين صارت في تشريعات ساعدتنا شوي
ولا في البدايه
بيخسرنا احنا كشركات لانها متعاقد معه
سنتين
فهذا اذا نقل في السنه الاولى انا خسرت
لان انا معاميلي متعاقد معه سنتين ومجدول
له
التكاليف على 24 شهر طيب هذا راح العامل
بدون موافقه عميلي ولا بدون موافقتي انا
وطلعت جديده ساعدتكم في المضارع الحين
غيروها شوي انه لازم العامل يكون عنده عقد
رسمي عشان سنقل لازم انه اروح حرف اذا ما
دفع الرسوم اللي حق اللي انا تعبت فيها
مثلا لازم اروح ارفع عليه دعوه في في
العدل في ارفع عليه قضيه ودعوه يعني
اجراءات خففت شوي عمليه سهوله النقل لكن
يقدر ينقل بعد سنه يقدر لكن انا حقوقي
اطالب فيها بعدين في الوزاره حاطه يعني
يعني شوي عاليه هذا الشيء
يخليك كثر التشريعات والتنظيمات يعني شوي
توقفك شوي عن النمو بالتالي انت تبغى ترجع
تفكر فيه كيف تطلع بافكار جديده خدمات
جديده منتجات جديده تعوض النقص اللي راح
يصير لك من تشريع جديد وهذا يوم قلت لك
العامل العامل الثالث اللي هو الفكر كويس
بيكون عندك استراتيجيه قويه
ومرنه انك تقدر تطلع بمنتجات جديده خدمات
جديده وتقدر تتمم فيها هذا اللي يساعدك
كثير بانك تستمر في في
قلنا راس المال بس قبل راس المال كفاءه
انا عندي اي بزنس جديد عندك لو عندك فكره
بسيطه
لو عندك راس مال من وجهه نظري الشخصيه
وعمليه في خبرتي بسيطه لو عندك ما يكفي
يجب يكون عندك الكفاءه اللي تشتغل لك
القائد اللي بيبدا يشتغل لك المشروع هذا
هذا الاساس اذا عندك القائد انت تقدر تجيب
الفلوس والفكر اللي تبدا تنضج حقك وتطوره
مع الوقت
وفكر هذا وجهه نظرك
اي بزنس تبغى تسويه لازم يكون عندك هو
التسريع
بطبيعتها تقيدك بس تشريعات اتحرك فرص
جديده
تحت الشخصيه
اتفائل كثير ورغم انه بعض التشريعات تجي
تقول تحس يحسون المنافسين او الزملاء اللي
معنا في القطاع انها بتضرهم لكن حنا نقول
دائما خذ الفكر في انه كيف تخلق فرصه منها
طلعوا قرار الوزاره 20% من المجموعه
العمالي عندك يجب تكون عماله منزليه
وخمسين بالمئه من العشرين بالمئه هذه يجب
تكون اعمال نسائيه
والا لن نعطيكم تاشيرات
الوزاره تحل مشكله العماله المنزليه اللي
ما في كان في وقتها ما كان فيه تعاقدات
كثير مع دول وما في احد يورد اعماله كثير
كويس لدول بسيطه جدا واندونيسيا مقفله
يمكن حنا في مهاره في وقتها قلنا هذه انا
باخذ التحدي بخلق منه فرصه كويس
واجتمعنا متعود على الجنسيه الاندونيسيه
في وقتها فكرنا كيف انا افتح اندونيسيا من
جديد كويس وهذه احد الفاليو قيم مضافه
اللي طلعناها في مهاره يعني
كخدمات القطاع بشكل عام خدمه المجتمع بشكل
عام حتى خففت الضغط شوي على الوزاره
فطلعنا بفكره انه نطلع مهنه جديده اسمه
عامت نظافه كويس وارسلناها بايميل
في وقتها وقتها الرئيس التنفيذي عندنا
وسبحان الله ارسلناها يمكن 11 بالليل
الساعه سته صباح رد مع الوزير قاعد توكل
على الله اوكي كانت هذه دفع قويه لنا وش
الفكره كانت انه اطلع مهنه جديده غير
الاسم عامله منزليه حلو
وعامل تضعفه
وعامه اضافه هذه وافقت الوزاره نبدا نجيب
نجيب عماله عليها اوكي والحمد لله بدينا
التقييد اللي كان موجود على المسمى الموقف
الاستخدام تماما وقتها كان واقف تمام يعني
المشكله كانت في المزمه بس كانت في المسمى
فطلعنا وجبنا فتحنا اندونيسيا هذا واقع
اليوم هذا واقع واليوم الحمد لله ماشيين
عليها
التحديات تولد فرص هذه قاعده عندي موجوده
مهما وضعوا التحديات او وجدنا تحديات في
تشريعات او شيء فهذه بيخلق منها
ممتاز
حنا اسسنا مجلس تنسيقي مجلس نسيقي بين
شركات المواد البشريه اليوم في ظهر 25
شركه معنا من اصل 43 اللي داخلين معنا
الهدف مجلس يصير يعني الوزاره بدل ما
تتكلم مع كل اربعين شركه 42 شركه يتكلم مع
مجلس يمثل 43 شركه
فهذه الامور التشغيليه والمشاكل اليوميه
للبزنس صارت مستجدات صارت اشياء نواجه
مشاكل معينه فكك عكس مع وكيل وزاره وعندنا
اجتماعات دوريه معهم في معالجه بعض الا
اذا في شيء معين سويه
اللجنه الوطنيه تختلف اللجنه الوطنيه
شكلناها قبل سنه ونص كويس
وانا نائب رئيس اللجنه فيها
عند الفكر فيها يختلف شوي اللجنه الوطنيه
انا اشيل قبعه مهاره من راسم في التمثيل
فاصير انا امثل كل القطع 43 شركه اللي معه
يمكن اليوم فامثل قطاع كامل كيف امثله
احرص اني كيف انمي الشركه الصغيره
او الشركات الجديده الناشئه لانه هدفنا في
اللجنه انه نقوي قطاعنا كيف اقويه اقويه
النار ابغى ممكنات القوه البنيه التحتيه
اللي موجوده في مهاره في
الموارد في كل الشركات الاركو كل الشركات
الموجوده ما بذكر اسم واجد معين غيرها
اني اخلي الشركات اللي توها ناشئه او اني
ما قدرت تنضج بشكل كبير ولا طلعت على
عددها على انها تصير زينا ليش كل ما
حوكمتها وكل ما قوته وكل ما صارت قويه وكل
ما الوزاره كم تساعدنا بماكنات جديده
وشافتنا ذراع قوي لها
فك انا حريص جدا ورئيس اللجنه ونائب رئيس
اللجنه اخر اللي معي انه لازم القطاعنا
يصير قوي على اساس انه ناخذ يعني مبادرات
من وزارات تعطيهم مبادرات اكثر وينمو
القطاع حقنا حنا ترك قطاعنا اليوم اثنين
بالمئه شكل من مجموع حجم العماله في
السعوديه وهذا رقم قليل جدا والباقي وين
رايح كله في السوق قطاع الحكومي يعني عند
اليوم حنا تقريبا قطاعنا كامل
42 شركه فيها 280 الف عامل بالمسوق حجم
العماله في القوى العامله في حر 6 مليون
بسيط جدا حنا طموحين نبغى نوصل عشره
بالمئه بعدها 15 بعدها 25% فشغلين الان في
اللجنه الوطنيه على برنامج
سميناه تمكين او تخصيص المواد
البشريه
داعمه كويس واحنا نسوي برنامج هذا نعرضها
عليهم وللامانه للامانه اتكلم بكل شفافيه
مع الوزير مرن ومنفتح ومعي النائب كذلك لو
جبنا لهم دراسات وهذا بالعكس هم يدعمونها
لكن في نفس الوقت حريصين انهم ما يضروا
القطاع الاخر فهم ينظرون يعني بنظره
شموليه اكثر انه يكون قطاعنا يعني هادف
وما يكون حنا مسيطرين على السوق
لابغى السوق منفتح لكن ممكن يمكنكم ببعض
الاشياء عشان كذا حنا نساعد الوزاره في
البرنامج هذا اللي بينمينا ويخلينا
مستدامين فيه يعني شوف اليوم
المعرفه في السوق والتوجه
خاصها الرؤيه رؤيه العهد في الرؤيه
الوطنيه احنا شايفين مشاريع يسمونها
وسبق مع الاستاذ نتكلم عنها
مشاريع فظيعه كبيره حتى العالم كله منبحه
منها يمكن بعض الناس ما يصدقونا بيصير هذا
لكن اليوم حنا نشوف هذا الواقع انا اليوم
جزء من عمالتي موجوده تشتغل في الميدان
هناك فالامر واقعي وفعلا بيصير اليوم يوصل
في اليوم بس يتوقعوا حول 400 500 الف عاما
الفتره الجايه رقمه بسيط من يوم يعني
بتصير مدن كبيره فيها بس هل في تحضر كلان
اي برامج او مستهدفات في الرؤيه تخدم
قطاعكم بعيد في موضوع المشاريع الترفيه
مشاريع السياحه مشاريع الفندقه مشاريع
الضيافه هذه كلها مشاريع تنمونا مو حنا
معها بس ما في شيء بشكل مباشر بشكل مباشر
في الرؤيه ما في شيء عشان كذا حنا اليوم
من اللجنه الوطنيه الاسس هذا البرنامج
اللي بيساعد وزاره ويساعدنا حنا ندخل
القطاع يعني حنا اليوم ممكن نخدم القطاع
الحكومي في السوق ما دخلناه يعني بدانا مع
هيئه كفاءه الانفاق وانا يعني بصراحه اثني
عليها انها يعني بدات تدعمنا كشركات مواد
بشريه في السوق انه تعالوا نعتمد عليكم
كشركات وطنيه فانك توفرون القوه العامله
حتى السعوديين اذا حبينا اذا بغينا هذه
عماله مؤقته
فكره اسناد بديناها
من بعد ما قلنا انه شفنا السوق
ما يقدر السعودي انه يشتغل مثلا في محل
قطع غيار او في محل
بقاله او
حلاقه ومغسله كويس لانه بيضل ما عنده لا
سيستم ما عنده ما يقدر يطلع قرض بنكي
حقه بيكون فقلنا لما يكون الفكره حقهم
عقودهم على شركات المواد البشريه
فيصير يعرف انه يرجع لشركه موارد بشريه
شركات قويه براس مال قوي
يستطيع انه التامين الطبي حقه كويس له
العائلته
يقدر يطلع قرض من البنك فحنا قوه اكثر من
المنشات الصغيره وبالتالي اقوم انا واعير
خدماته واسند خدماته الى المحل الصغير هذا
فهنا بيتقبل السعوديين انه يشتغل كانت هذه
فكره انه كيف انا اخليهم يستديمون لن
يستدين هو في محل صغير لكن قلنا بيستدين
لما يكون على عكده على شركات كبرى في نجاه
الفكره حقنا في انه كيف انا اطور
السعوديين فيها
فبداناها فعليا ان المهاره يمكن وظفنا فوق
السبع مئه السعودي في سنه
الحمد لله مستدين الى السوق وهذا شيء
ايجابي وطيب
للامانه طلبنا من الوزاره انهم يعطونا
ممكنات فيها ووعدونا خير
ازيد العدد الى اعداد كبيره واساعد في اني
اخفض عدد البطاله في البلد فكانت هذه
الفكره بشكل عام بس
شركات حكوميه مثلا توظف الجهاز حكوميه
احنا احنا المفروض بعض الشركات الحكومه
المفروض ما تسوي المفروض لان هذا شغلنا
حنا وهذا اللي احنا جايين نقول وزاره انه
نحتاج حكمه اكبر ان القطاعات المرخصه فقط
منكم هم يتقدم الخدمه اللي عنده ترخيص
يقدم خدمات توظيف السعوديين للجهات
الحكوميه او غيرها حنا اليوم مع الحمد لله
هيئه كفاءه الانفاق بدانا اول جهه يعني
تعتبر اللي دخلتني عن قطاع الحكومي العام
وبدانا معهم لنا سنه الان الحمد لله كملنا
سنه فعين هذه بدايه السنه الثانيه تجربتنا
ناجحه جدا حتى هم يقدرون يقيمونها في
تجربتهم وجميله هذه بيخلينا او يدعمنا او
يدعم
انها توسع نطاق انه يعتمدون علينا كشركات
في توفير القوى العامله سواء السعوديه او
غير السعوديه
حتى في شركات ثانيه بالقطاع الخاص سياره
توفر الخدمه
حلو على سيره المنافسين في يمكن عده
لاعبين في السوق سواء الناس اللي في النفس
نوعيه شركتكم كشركات مواد البشريه براس
مال مرتفع او بلاعبين اخرين نتكلم اول شيء
عن الشركات اللي تشتغل في نفس راس المال
حقهم الشركات
طرح وش الفرق الجوهري بينكم
حنا التزام عالي لان حنا يحكمنا اكثر مو
بوزاره الموارد البشريه فقط حكم الماء
كويس وهاي السوق المال حريصه جدا يكون
مجلس اداره حقك مجلس يعني في اعضاء
مستقلين وليس يكون من نفس انهم كلهم غير
مستقلين او تنفيذين في الشركه هذا شيء
ايجابي كبير انه يكون اعضاء مستقلين من
خارج الشركه تكون في لجان لجنه مراجعه وهي
موجوده في الشركات لكن تكون قويه جدا
المراجعه الخارجي يكون حقك قوي جدا لانك
انت تنشر قوائمك الماليه وكل اشيائك واي
شيء يصير عندك في الشركه خلل او شيء او
انه شيء جديد او كبير لازم تفصح عنه
وتعلونه في السوق بالتالي حوكمه والتزامه
لان اليوم ما هم ساهمين فقط عندهم يعني زي
شركات اخرى ما طرحت
المساهمين ليس هم فقط صار المساهمين
المجتمع صناديق الاستثماريه جهات اجنبيه
بالتالي لازم تفصح عن كل شيء في السوق
وهذا اثروا عليكم حسب تجربتكم انك تفصح عن
كل شيء وعنشر ارقامك مقابل كل الشركات
الثانيه
بس مهاره تطلع قوائمها الماليه على اساس
نشوف ميزات وعيوبها ونعدل موجبها حنا
متضررين مهاره لان حنا ما نشوف ارقامهم
وحنا طالبين يعني انه يكون كل البيانات
منشوره حق الشركات ما هو لاجل اني اشوف
لكن لاجل اني احسن في خدماتي او في
مصاريفي او في اشيائي الثانيه هم صاروا
يشوفون احنا ما بنشوفهم
حريص انه شركات كثيره لازم تدخل في السوق
في سوق الاسهم وتصير مدرجه في السوق تقيس
ادائك مقابل ادائك نعم فعليا
انهم ينظرون كلهم كيف كمان المهاره اللي
هي لان هي الوحيده من 42 شركه اللي قائمها
منشوره او حتى بياناتها او حتى احصائياتها
عنا حلو هذول المنافسين المبشرين في
المنافسين
هل تشوفونهم في دائرتكم يعني
خدمه التوسط انه يجيب عامل او عامله على
فيزا الفرد كويس
شويه بس ما هو ما هو كبير
هل هم يعتبرونكم مثلا
الان صار عندهم الميزه اللي ما هي يعني
اللي يسوونها هم الان ياخذون يقدرون
يجيبون تاجير او تقديم الخدمه
بالعشر الان ايه اللي بتحتاج راس مال 20
مليون
فيقدر يسويها والوزاره تدعمهم الان في
انهم يندمجون ويتركون الى شركه
وهذا
يعني ما اقدر
انظمه الفلبين ما تساعدني
بس مكاتب الاستخدام فلبينية وغيرها انا ما
اقدر يعني اقدر اسويها ما ابغى اسويها
لانها متعبه شوي ومزعجه حلو طب هذا جاهز
المكاتب الاستقدام بخصوص التطبيقات اللي
يستخدمون
عن عمل موسمي والعمل
هل هذا برضو في تقاطع بينكم
بدينا من الاشياء اللي بنقدم نفس الخدمه
هذه لكن حنا ما نقدر لانه نحاول انه مع
الوزاره نشتغل عليها انه نسويها لانه
اليوم انا اجيب السعودي واسندب بعقود مع
مع الشركات مع المستفيدين منهم
هذول يقدمون خدمه
بالساعه او باليوم او بالشهر في الاربعين
يرجع
له تنظيم خاص مختلف تماما كويس وهم يختلف
تنظيمهم عن تنظيمنا بس العمل هذا
الموسم
كبير
في في ظل التوجه جديد في موضوع الترفيه
ولا سياحه وفي مواسم تحتاج وتقدر نقدر
نقدمها بس عدم دخلكم فيما له علاقه بالسوق
كثر
بالعكس ممكن نقدمها وندخل بالسوق ونمشي
فيها بس نحتاج بس بعض التعديلات في
التشريعات او المرونه شوي نقدم اعماله
مؤقته ممكن تتحولون على واحد ممكن بالعكس
كثير
بس برجع لك للاستراتيجيه حقنا احنا
الاستراتيجيتنا سهله ومبسطه وكانت
مبنيه على ثلاث محاور رئيسيه محورين
داخل المهاره يعني كلها تعني بمهاره محور
الثالث اخر محور الاول يتعلق بتقويه
البنيه التحتيه في الشركه سواء من كيف
اتحول في راس الماء البشري كيف احافظ على
كفاءه مهاره كيف انمي الكفاءات واطورها
كيف استثمر في الكفاءات موضوعك كيف تقويه
النظام التقني كيف اخلي السيستم حقي ينضج
ويستوعب الاف مئات الاف العماله وطوروا كل
شوي واتميز فيه
هذه هو يتخلى كل البنيه التحتيه بشكل عام
كيف اطور السياسات واجراءات حقي مصفوفه
الصلاحيات الهيكله الاداريه لتكون مناسبه
جدا لنموذج عمل حق الداخلي اللي يساعدني
في النمو هذا هو المحور الاول
التحتيه المحور الثاني اللي هو نفس البزز
حقنا اني انضج وانمو فيه اللي هو قطاع
الاعمال قطاع الافراد قطاع خدمه الساعه
قطع اسناد السعوديين كيف اطلع خدمات جديده
في منتجات جديده واشتغل عليها ومنها طلعنا
اشياء حلوه في التدريب في التطوير منتجات
جديده تعلق بخدمه الساعه خدمه الساعه
بادوات النظافه خدمه الساعه باجهزه بتنظيف
العميق هذه اشياء كثيره بدينا فيها وطورنا
فيها المحور الثالث اللي هو بيتكلم عليه
اللي هو
اكتشاف فرص جديده
قد يكون منها جزء في يخدم القطاع ويجوز
اخر لاخر من القطاع وهذا اللي بحرنا فيه
حنا بدينا فيه يمكن في يعني بشكل عميق في
السنه الماضي
يعني قد ما يكون في علاقه بالقطاع ليش
تروح لشيء
خارجتين اللي هو تنوع الفرص والخدمات في
فرص تشوفها موجوده اليوم في السوق
بتساعدك في النمو في الاستدامه قد يكون في
علاقه بسيطه معك مثلا احنا استعودنا على
حصه في مستشفى المملكه
41% مستشفى المملكه
القطاع الصحي فيه رؤيه كبيره وفي نمو كبير
وفي تخصيص كبير جاي عليه المملكه بالتالي
حنا عندنا شايفين فرص قادمه في قطاع الصحي
فالفرص واعده
في مجالين في القطاع الصحي مستشفى المملكه
وفي شركه متخصصه بالهوم كير بالرعايه
المنزليه الصحيه برعايه الصحيه المنزليه
ليش انا شايفين في الفرس فرص بتكون كبيره
واعده
فاستبقنا السوق ومشينا فيها المستشفى
مملكه ياخذ تمريض من عندنا ياخذ اطباء
بالتالي انا فيه في سنرجع فيه في في تناغم
بيننا
الرعايه الصحيه المنزليه اليوم فيه رؤيه
كبيره وزاره الصحه انها تنزل يعني او تخرج
المرضى من المستشفيات ترعاهم في البيوت
هذا يحتاج تمريض يكون موجود في البيت
تمريض المنزلي وهذا يحتاج تمريض يكون من
عندنا او من السوق بشكل عام من الشركه
نفسها بالتالي نقدم خدمه
اللي هو مستشفى في بيتك
مرتبطه بشكل مباشر هذه مرتبطه بشكل هذي
كلها خدمات يتم تشغيلها من العماله
الماليه تكون من عندنا في استحواذ الثانيه
يمكن ما لها علاقه كبيره هنا لكن في سنرجي
بسيط اني نقدم له عماله بشكل بسيط لكن في
استحواذات يعني من عندنا يعني زي اكاديميه
التدريب هذه بتدرب مهاره بشكل مئه بالمئه
انا خلاص موقف التدريب عندي من موظفيني
ومعطيه الاكاديميه بس ما تقررت تفتح
اللي هو تطوير الاعمال كويس اللي هذا شوفي
فرص جديده واعده في السوق فنبدا
الاكاديميه زي عندنا يوم بدات موضوع تنظيم
توصيل المطاعم والهادي مع الشركات شركات
التوصيل اللي هي منصات التشاركيه وفرصه
وضعها
على طول طلعنا ترخيص كويس كويس
في مجال لوجستي
وطلعنا جبنا سائقين وجبنا السيارات
والوزاره ما قصرت تاشيرات لها
فهذه فرص جديده واعده وعندنا خبره في
اداره البشر في اداره القوى العامله
وعندنا التنظيم وعندنا وعندنا هذا وبدانا
وعندنا قوه املاء الماليه فبدانا نتوسع في
النشاط وهذا يسميه اني انوع الفرص حق
الشركه وهذا سبحان الله شوف جاحه كورونا
علمتنا كثير كويس احنا كان عندنا بس تقديم
خدمات عماليه وقد جائحه كورونا معظم
العملاء توقفت عندي كويس فتره طويله كويس
يعني ما في الا نشاطين ثلاث انشطه كانت
تشتغل في الوقت هذاك لكن جزء كبير من
العماله ما تشتغل
فهذا اعطانا درس شوي انه لازم انوع
بخدماتي لازم افكر في شيء جديد لو توقف
هذا يشتغل هذا صح كويس وهذا احنا لاننا
ضغط علينا اكبر من غيرنا لان حنا شركه
مساهمه والمساهمين ما يرحمون المساهم يعني
حاط يعني استثماراته في الشركه لاجل انه
يبغاك تنمي تنمي
يعني المبالغ اللي حطها فيه وتنميها وتخلي
قطاع وعاج احنا في مهاره كانت استراتيجيه
الاولى في 2018 كانت مبنيه على خمس سنوات
كويس وجاء وقتها الان انتهت اليوم حنا
نسوي استراتيجيه الثانيه حقنا بتكون على
خمس سنوات بعد الاستراتيجيه فيها عوامل
جديده مع التغيرات الجديده مع النهضه
الجديده مع الرؤيه الجديده
ايضا ممكن كورونا غيرت اشياء كثيره في
الاقتصاد بالتالي لازم يجب ان اليوم ننفتح
على اشياء جديده
يمكن نحتاج ثلاثه شهور استراتيجياتنا وراح
تعلن رسمي لاحقا لاحقا في يعني على على
داخل الشركه ونبدا تنفيذها على خمس سنوات
وهذه كل كل خمس سنوات لازم تسوي
استراتيجيه جديده
فمهاره ان شاء الله مع الرؤيه جديده مع
التوجهات الجديده مع جيجا اتوقع انه يكون
لنا حصه سوقيه اكبر فتره قادمه نتوقع انه
الشركات اللي استعودنا عليها في الفتره
الماضيه انها تمضج وتتعدل وتتصحح وتغير
مسارها والشركات القائمه بعكس راح تزيد
وترتفع بشكل كبير فان شاء الله في نمو وفي
توجه كبير وفي دعم كبير مجلس اداره مجلس
اداره عندنا متمكنه الحمد في قوه كبيره
جدا شكل من عده تخصصات اللي في مجال
التطوير البزنس وفي مجال البانكينج في
الاستثمارات في الحوكمه في الالتزام في كل
المجالات فان شاء الله انه نتوقع انه يكون
في نهضه كبيره وانه ننطلق ونقفز قفزات
كبيره الفتره القادمه ان شاء الله يا رب
في البرنامج فشكرا لك وشكرا لكم وللبرنامج
الطيب هذا نسال الله نكون ضيف خفيف عليكم
وانه يستفيد الجميع من يعني المحاضره اللي
صارت الله يعطيك العافيه شكرا ان شاء الله
قبل ما تقفلوا الحلقه اتمنى اذا عجبتك
تشاركها مع اللي حولك وتقيمها بتقييم
ايجابي سواء في اليوتيوب او في ايتونز
واذا كان عندكم ملاحظات عنها
سواء على ايميل البرنامج سوالف ات 8.com
او حتى على حسابي في تويتر ات دبي شكرا
لمتابعتكم وشكرا لعبد الملك ال سعيد في
اعداد الحلقه ياسر الغانم في اداره
التصوير بالاضاءه غال محمد ومساعده الياسر
الكدشه في الاخراج الابداعي وهاب موسى في
الاخراج الفني مجد القرشي في الهندسه
الصوتيه عبد العزيز المزي في التحرير
برامج بيبان في التجهيز عبد المجيد عمر
عبد الله بن الفقيه محمد عبد العزيز او في
الانتاج التنفيذي رزاند هيثم هذا سوالف
بزنس احد منتجات شركه 8 للنشر والتوزيع